[تصفيق]
ت السلام عليكم السلام ورحمه الله كيفك
تمام الحمد لله كان وياك مقلوب كده تقول
بدقل يا اخي خل استهبال يا اخي رساله معرف
نقراها رساله ك اشوف
من الشركه ده بالعربي بالعربي يا اخي ما
نعرف لا نقرا ولا نكتب شاب عمره 25 سنه
ولا يعرف لا يقرا ولا يكتب هذه مصيبه لا
تستغربون هذه قصه حقيقيه حصلت في 2010
وقتها فكرت كيف ممكن اساعد مثل هؤلاء
الشباب فطلعت لي فكره ان نسوي برنامج بسيط
يعني نبعد شويه عن محو الاميه سميته قلم
للابداع
في
2011 قدمت لعده جهات للتمويل الاولى قالت
لي ا الميزانيه عفوا الاحصائيات اللي
قدمتها كبيره 40% نسبه اميه في حض موت مش
معقول طبعا دي احصائيات رسميه مش معقول
نعدل فيها رحت المنظمه الثانيه قالت لي
انه الميزانيه اللي قدمتها كبيره ضخمه
خفضنا الميزانيه سويناها 800 دولار مشينا
عمل لعدد 42 شاب على على مستوى مدينه
المكله بدينا مرحله برنامج محميه
بسيط دعيت رجل
خير شاف الشباب وقال لي هل في كثير قلت له
مليان قاللي استمر واي شيء عندي من
هنا من هنا كانت
الانطلاقه
مره
[موسيقى]
خير خير دداخل ه عرض ناس يقولون السلام
عليكم يدقون الباب شويه واحد مشغول واححد
برزه كده
شويه منتعلم يا اخي طيب طيب من سجلك طيب
كذا حبه حبه
ك طيب عب الاستماره مسك ما نعرف لا نقرا
ولا نكتب ا طيب انت الا معروف بعبك
الاستمار
انا ايش تشتغل
اشتغل سيل سيل قاطع
طريق كيف قاطع طريق كيف فهمنا بالعربي
نوقف اول الشارع اي سياره بتعبر ما بيعبر
الا ما يدفع وعبر يتحمل نجيله حلال ولا مو
حلال طيب طيب خلاص بعد فتره من
تعليمه
[تصفيق]
تصوروا بعد فتره من تعليمه جاب لي بشكم مع
شباب جابهم ايه عندي قلت له خير قال لي
شوف هذ بغيتهم يتعلمون ونبض منهم قلت له
ان شاء الله وقال لي انا حسيت بالذنب ما
بغيتهم يصيرون
مثلي من هنا فكرنا كيف نطور البرنامج في
2012 دربنا
254 شاب وشابه طبعا بدل ما يكون برنامج
محميه اصبح برنامج
محميه
حاسوب دورات مهنيه
وحرفيه اداره وتشغيل مشاريع صغيره وبرضه
اضفنا اساسيات انجليزي تنميه
بشريه في 2013 دربنا 330 شاب
وشابه 2014 اصبحنا مؤسسه وتوسع نشاطنا بدل
ما نشمل منطقه واحده خطينا عده مناطق في
حضرموت ليصبح عدد المتدربين والمتدربات
1007 متدرب
ومتدربه طبعا في مخرجات كثير وقصص كثيره
لكن بجيب لكم
الاهم مره في اثنين
رمضان دخلت مسجد وشفت واحد من شباب
ينادينا استا فادي جيت ها كيفك تمام قال
جزاكم الله خير انتم والداعمين اول مره في
حياتي نمسك كتاب
الله يعني هذا الموقف خلاني نفرح وان نفكر
كيف نساعد مثل هؤلاء الشباب
ومره كذلك في شاب من الخريجين عنده طموح
وصل انه يكون بطل الجمهوريه في السباحه
2012 فئه
الناشئين ومره جاني اتصال من واحد صاحبي
قاللي يا فاذ اب انا واحد محاسب على يدك
مش مهم الخبره اهم شيء يكون امين قلت له
على ضمانتي نحن في عندنا ميزه في البرنامج
انه مش ان احنا ندرب ونرمي لا نحن عندنا
التواصل بالتليفون واتساب فيسبوك يعني
كلهم ما شاء الله المتخرجين عندهم تواصل
اجتماعي فقلت له موجود اتصلت بالشاب قلت
له يا اخي شوف نحنا حصلنا لك شغل براتب 30
قاللي كم الراتب قلتله 30 الف في الشهر
حلو قاللي تستهبلي يا استاذ فاذ ش نسلم في
اسبوع 3
الف وعاده قال راتبي اكثر من
راتبك
اصبح يمتلك مهنه في
الجبس اتعلمون خريج ثاني ابتدائي هذا
الشاب خريج ثاني
ابتدائي ومش كده انا اتمنيت انه يكون
موجود هنا مشان تشوفونه هو الان عنده
مقاوله في
عدن طبعا قلت لكم في كثير من
القصص طيب وبرضه في شاب
خريج خريج ثانوي واللي فاجئنا انه جاب
امتياز قسم ادبي جاب امتياز قسم
ادبي
طيب مخرجات
كثيره حلمنا ان تكون نسبه الاميه في
حضرموت 0% بحلول عام 202 لا للاميه في
حضرموت all